welcome to this video playing con
tourist contour wrist let's see ireland
silent right so this laughs good old
sloth um they are taking I don't know
that well okay play rather play the
Chairman ankhon at least have experience
with that I can't get the exchange
variation not very thrilling can i play
this a bit a bit more interesting with
Queen a five or something like that this
Bishop to g5 as a bit is a bit odd maybe
maybe I can get some play going here
with quick quick pin motives
what do now something that group c 1
okay on this is this is running right
into Bishop f5 isn't it I don't this is
a comb this is a weird move threatening
also to take on c3 or 93 okay moves it
again let's see if I take em b7 night be
for us also directly I go going further
for the for the kill here maybe why not
actually why not taking on c3 night c2s
a pretty pretty big threat so now i can
at least rather take on c3 rook takes
Knight a to Queen B seven Roxy 893 have
a look check so I can take it to anyway
btx night a 2 okay let's do that I don't
see why I shouldn't
night a to Queen B seven maybe I what I
have Roxy and I really have Wow yeah
okay I need to take you in any case Roxy
to be one I can just take it's all about
queen bee seven but I thought rook c8
and and what is the the big the big
point Queen takes a six maybe I can also
just take the rook but this does not
look so great okay c8 Queen a six is
this really working no I can't rate rate
xe1 and at the end I'm I'm a piss-up
okay so that that's good then I don't
see a move ready for wide as the rook
Hanks let its so I have a very messy
position can easily overlook some stuff
okay strangled trying this one so i can
take the rook now he's threatening what
we should be five but this is just a
check at the moment it will it will be
difficult and our dangerous i mean in
any case yeah okay she should be five
king here
25 oh I overlooked 25 total name here
also I think this wasn't this just
winning Queen d5 I mean this is this is
dangerous here in any in any case but 25
okay I cannot play six this much is
clear she always takes down 25 I mean
cannot take on c3 those what the
position groups is seven Roxy 725 Bishop
d7 might be okay I don't know Annie to
play with him
maybe this was okay Queen ph maybe queen
be a drug see it should be at least okay
from black check I don't let's do this
first and then think about if I have
something else you should see eight for
example
25 57s draw a head check yeah can i play
for win here I'd love to Bishop siad
threatens time morning Fred through p7
icon I'm gambling with this now he said
I missed Queen txt 5 yeah right yeah
this was was a very lucky moment for me
I have rook v7 threatening made night f7
made but I can take no I cannot I this
is not even attract oh my god ah cannot
move this
okay it still made like a shiny limit of
course what a game pou Chen kind of game
where the comp love and laughs and
laughs at your face I'm pretty sure
black is nice winning here in this
position but it's it's why no I liked
winning I'm lost this is this surprises
me really this the tech is really a win
yeah okay this business as Queen takes
d5 of course but where where was I
winning I mean never never ever is this
good for white of course where where was
I winning Brooke ta-da must play it must
play look the aid this is much Beckham
rookie head okay hmm yeah but this is
only a better for black not winning or
anything Bishop a six is the line night
c1 and castles so I'm a whole look up
but still not winning why the night is
here the night is almost trapped as c
and s 95
yeah and after this I'm losing I'm
probably just am losing Jesus was Queen
d5 was just check just killing him here
but it wasn't as easy i shot bishop GE
actually but this this is not winning
here black wins funny enough but Quincy
for that's good and only then the check
now I'm losing and losing the house him
ah what a game stack what what happened
he didn't see that and went castles and
it's still winning and that check is
just too strong check yeah this is a
chef Frankie made check mate check yeah
okay is also a major and I didn't have
any defense so how exactly was what what
was my mistake I mean Quincy to this
this is not good for white of course
losing a tempo with g5 h4 and and here I
really a Quint Quincy to just gives me a
move so I definitely must be a must be
okay here but probably and I made some
mistake but where is the mistake night
before not before it's not good so I
must take maybe keep it to the keep it
simple approach yeah what needs to
recapture if he takes with the Queen
then I before it's very strong rook c8
Quincy to is too much so we must take
with the pawn and then then just rook c8
something like that and he has the week
see porn yeah this is in fact very good
for black that's very comfortable yeah
this is what I must do so my way to try
to punish him for Quincy to be three
those things was just wrong
or at least it wasn't it wasn't leading
to room 222 an edge for black and they
are up the eighth but this is a very
very fishy position okay so I played it
play wrong I needed to play takes on c3
instead of night before okay thanks for
watching